on va passer à Jade et Joy ah vous
connaissez Jade et Joy je ne connais que
Jade Jade et Joy qui sont qui font chier
là à m'appeler là pendant l'émission je
vais m'énerver hein je vous le dis hein
Mustapha là qui m'appelle là m'appelle
encore une fois je vais m'occuper de lui
ce soir euh on va revenir sur les
récentes interview de Jad adidé leur
relation avec David et Laura la mort de
leur père le harcèlement qu'elle subit
sur les réseaux sociaux on en parle ce
soir avec Benjamin lcog journaliste chez
Paris Match et Roland prez proche de
sylviean et davidid bien sûr l'avocat
qu'on adore qui est souvent avec Pascal
de la tour du
pzimt tous avec
pas cette
émission les
gars il y a quelques jours les filles
adoptives de laticia et Johnny ALID
avaient accordé une interview exclusive
à Paris Match elle nous parle de leur
vie à Los Angeles elle nous parle de
leur père et ce weekend les deux jeunes
femmes
de 15 et 19 ans ont réalisé leur premier
entretien télévisé dans l'émission 7 à 8
une interview dans laquelle elle raconte
avoir subi du harcèlement évoque leur
relation avec leur mère David et Laura
et parle avec émotion de leur papa
décédé en 2017 c'était un père
attentionné généreux alors que disel
dans ce nouvel entretien relation avec
David et Laura mort de Johnny menace de
mort retour sur les interviews de Jad et
Joy ALID ce soir dans
TPMP
cartonn merci d'être avec nous Benjamin
leoch merci
journaliste par biographe de Joh et
merci à Roland prez d'être là Roland
c'est toujours un bonheur de te voir tu
fais partie de la famille que tu es avec
pascaloui j'ai vu que tu as recyclé tous
les avocats de de Paf ici bien bah comme
vous êtes payé je me dis bah voilà ah ou
d'accord l'émission coûte moins cher je
toujours heureux tu sais comment je suis
merci Roland d'être avec nous et c'est
vrai qu'hier première interview c'est
fou cette interview et c'est vrai que
alors je vais vous dire on peut pas
mettre on va vous dire ce qui s'est dit
dans l'interviewevenenir dessus puis
Benjamin c'était en fait vous avez fait
une interview au commune en fait avec 7
à 8 c'est ça alors il y a eu quatre
médias qui sont partis à Los Angeles
pour rencontrer les filles à l'occasion
de l'exposition de Johnny alidday qui
ouvre le 21 décembre ou le 21 décembre
dis donc voilà donc on IR ensemble on
ira ensemble si tu veux il y a eu donc
quatre médias français une radio une
télé et deux presse très bien alors
Paris Match étaé Benjamin magnifique non
franchement il est exceptionnel Benjam
je tiens à le dire voilà je suis
toujours content de te voir alors on va
revenir sur ce qui s'est dit parce que
et on va revenir avec Roland P sur toute
l'histoire de cette parce que c'est vrai
qu'on les avait jamais entendu moi je
les aime bien moi Jad des Joy en plus
ouis ouais je trouve qu'elles ont un
truc je sais pas j'aime bien
elles ont un peps tu vois ou pas faire
voir Jad Joy que Gill Verdes par exemple
euh l'interview s'est bien déroulé
c'était sympa écoute donc c'est Caroline
mangez la directrice de la rédaction qui
l'a faite elle m'a dit que c'était
extrêmement bien passé tout comme
toujours chez les alidé ça a duré très
longtemps c'était pareil pour TF1
c'està-dire que il y avait des créneaux
prévus d'une heure finalement ça a duré
2h la séance photo a duré aussi comme a
temps de Johnny où tu avais rendez-vous
à 14h et les choses démarraient à 18h
mais donc tout le planning a été
chamboulé mais tout s'est très bien
passé et donc elles ont joué le jeu à
fond sans la présence de laticia il y
avait des questions interdites ou pas
non aucune question interdit ah bah non
sinon sinon on arrête tout sinon on y va
pas non non l'idée c'était que Jade et
Joy ne s'étent jamais exprimé on avait
envie de savoir qui était quelle était
leur relation avec leur père et même
elles sont venu sur les terrains F enfin
les les dernières fâcheries et notamment
leur relation avec leurs frères et leurs
sœurs David et justement c'est là c'est
le moment j'ai envie de dire le climax
de cette interview elles ne sont pas
tendres ah non elles sont pas tendres du
tout non ouais vous avez senti qu'elles
étaient Caroline Carol a dit non mais ça
a été terrible parce qu'elles sont enfin
voilà elles sont toujours elles sont
choquées par l'attitude que Laura et
David ont pu avoir c'est-à-dire que le
jour des obsèques de Johnny à La
Madeleine c'est on sera toujours là pour
vous et depuis plus rien alors moi jeis
vous direi j'ai mon ami Jean-Claude
d'Armont qui est cité hein parce qu'
l'ont cité cité avec lu avec comme ceux
comme ceux qui ont tourné la un ami
et c'est quelqu'un vraiment qui est je
peux vous dire extrêmement droit et qui
malheureusement ne peut pas faire ce
qu'il veut apparemment puisqu'il y a des
blocages de partout et que il peut pas
il aimerait voilà avoir des contacts
avec J des JO mais malheureusement c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué
que ce qu'elles peuvent dire dans
l'interview également c'est ce que m'ont
dit les gens en tout cas qui ont été
cités euh Roland oui je pense que depuis
depuis la mort de un peu déjà avant la
mort de Johnny et après la mort de
Johnny je crois que tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il y a eu un
véritable blocage un véritable tissu
enfin cordon sanitaire qui s'est fait
autour de la famille alidé et qui a
empêché à la fois les enfants et c'est
les enfants qui l'ont dit eux-mêmes de
voir leur père avant le avant son départ
et puis aujourd'hui dans cette article
qui est d'ailleurs très bien fait les
les l'interview AC était très bien mené
mais à un moment donné on a posé une
question qui était très juste au au de
au deux petites fill au deux jeunes
filles on leur a dit quels étaient vos
liens avant c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est pas après et avant avant elles ont
dit tout de suite bah on nait pas
vraiment de lien avant on est on nhabite
pas dans le même pays on n pas du tout
le même âge euh notre père voilà ma mère
avait essayé de de reconstruire une
famille décomposé c'est ce qu'elle dit
c'est ce qu'elles disent toutes les deux
euh et et là on a vraiment laention on
touche du doigt vraiment une sorte
d'instrumentalisation de ces deux jeunes
filles à l'égard tout d'un coup des
curelles d'héritage des relations entre
les grands et et les et les enfants et
ces deux jeunes fillumentalisation vous
y allez fort parce que je pense quand
même que c'était ça s'est passé il y a 6
ans elles ont eu le temps de réfléchir
elles ont eu le temps de se dire est-ce
qu'on y va est-ce que est-ce qu'on y va
pas elles ont eu le temps de prendre du
recul sur tout ça certes elles avaient 9
et 13 ans quand les choses sont passées
maintenant elles ont 15 et 19 donc elles
ont eu le temps de de se faire leur
propre réflexion par rapport à cette
histoire là comme vous l'avez bien dit
laetia a tout fait pour que la famille
existe effectivement quand il y a pas de
volonté d'un côté comme de l'autre si N
ça n'a pas lieu j'ai j'ai toujours une
petite une petite anecdote est-ce que
vous savez combien de fois Johnny a été
voir David sur
scène bah vous S a une question c'est
que c'est zéro merci Cyril ah oui je
suisell ça montre l'état de leur
relation quand même c'est-à-dire que la
relation David Johnny elle était
compliquée on pe on peut ne pas avoir de
connaissance mais grâce à son
intelligence on arrive à trouver les
bonnes
réponses en forme monsieur non non mais
zéro il a jamais été le voir ils ont
chanté ensemble il y a eu il y a eu
quelques duos vous entendez ça aller au
concert de son fils ne l'a pas fait ça
l'a pas empêché d'écrire le meilleur
album pour son pour son père donc je
pense qu' ils avaient ils avaient les
relations qu'ils avaient et je pense
qu'il y avait pas de difficulté pour
qu'il puisse avoir des relations mais on
voit bien que les petites quand je dis
instrumentalisation je pèse mes mots
parce que les les deux petites
reviennent sur le procès tout d'un coup
elles avaient 9 ans et 13 ans qu'est-ce
qu'elle savaient de ce procès et
pourtant elle parle on nous a assigné
alors qu'en réalité non on ne les a mis
en cause que pour pour leur permettre de
toucher l'héritage puisqu'on leur on
demandait 75 % divisit en quatre en
quatre parts alors qu'elle n'était pas
dans l'héritage donc les deux les deux
grands au contraire on on les ont mis
dans ce dans cette dans cette procédure
au même titre que laassassem au même
titre que les éditions de musique au
même titre que d'autres personnes
uniquement pour ouvrir le partage de
l'héritage donc ça prouve bien qu'elles
sont là instrumentalisé puisquelles
viennent dire on nous a assigné on nous
a fait un procès alors que cont
justement ce n'était pas un procès
contre elle euh latiticia était présente
bien entendu non Laetiticia était pas
présente pendant les interviews elle est
venue elle est venue pour la séance
photo mais elle a laissé toutes les
interviews se faire sans elle parce que
sinon le procès était déjà là et les
questions n'avaient pas été envoyées
avant non non non céta après ce qu' ce
qu'elles ont dit à TF1 ce qu'elles
disent dans parismch et ce qu'elles
disent dans Le Parisien c'est un peu les
mêmes choses parce que les questions
tournent autour de tournent autour des
mêmes thèmes mais il a des mots forts
hein trahison mensonge abandon c'est des
mots c'est c'est des mots qui ne
s'accompagnent pas de ce qu'elle disait
des relations qu'elles avaient avant
puisqu'elle disait qu'ils avaient pas de
relation avant donc pourquoi parler de
tout d'un coup de trahison de mensonge
de c'est c'est là où j'ai j'ai
l'impression que on sait alors c'est mon
mon hble avis mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on s'est servi d'elle pour faire la
promotion d'un d'une exposition qui
arrivve alors que ce sont effectivement
les les deux les deux les deux jeunes
enfants de Johnny mais on les met tout
d'un coup en avant en
interview on les met en avant dans un
reportage télé uniquement en réalité
pour servir la promotion d'une
exposition et je trouve ça un peu un peu
dommage elles ont droit de s'exprimer
elles ont la totale liberté de s'exprim
s'exprimer elles étaient très mignonnes
quand elles ont parlé effectivement de
leur de leur peine de leur de leur
relation à leur père tout ça était
effectivement très très joli très
sensible mais mais au regard de ce
qu'ils disent sur sur le grand frère et
et la sœur on a vraiment l'impression
qu'ils sont téléguidés Patrick moi je
trouve que la vie de Roland pour le coup
est téléguidé et biaisé je vous apprécie
beaucoup mais là je trouve que mais non
mais vous pour idé vous pourfondz
maisidé par qui ça je ne sais pas vous
allez nous le dire parce c'est vous qui
le dit c'est pas moi qui dit c'est vous
qui le dites donc tu esgidé par qui
pourfonderer le libre arbitre de deux
jeunes filles de 15 et 19 ans à 15 et 19
ans quand on a baigné tout le temps dans
les affaires d'héritage quand on a
entendu le mot justice on peut tout à
fait avoir son sentiment là vous avez
l'impression pour aller au bout de V
pardon pourqu vous êtes énervé non mais
par je ser éé ligidé par qui je ne sais
pas par qui aller au bout aller au bout
de par David et vous auez du tout tout
Dav pas alors je ne viens pas pour David
parce que David ne sa absolument pas
exprimer
parle dans
la ne s même pas exprimé dans son propre
livre il n'a pas réglé ses compes moi je
rappeller juste une chose VO le mal
partout il y a eu un accord qui a été
fait entre les les deux enfants de
Johnny dans cet accord il y a une
confidentialité donc laticia ne
s'exprime pas David et Laura ne
s'expriment pas et curieusement bah les
deux jeunes filles s'expriment parce
qu'elles ne sont pas parties à ce
protocole
d'acordand et on a l'impression qu'on
veut réhabiliter totalement Benjamin
dans un instant les chéris parce que on
va revenir aussi moi je voudrais
qu'onevienne aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux je sais que voilà K peut pas
s'exprimer dessus parce que il y a un
petit voilà exactement voilà mode jeis
en motus c'est très bien donc c'est très
bien euh sinon sur Oui Mad je voulais
revenir sur cet article alors évidemment
c'est un
gros V non mais c'est un gros c'est un
gros mais c'est un gros coup pour Paris
Match incontestablement et évidemment
ces deux jeunes filles sont absolument
charmantes et touchantes mais j'espère
qu'elles sont solides et j'espère
qu'elles sont structurés parce que moi
je trouve qu'on les pipolise d'une
manière folle elles ont que 15 et 19 ans
alors elles ont été pour le coup
pipolisé par leurs parents d oui mais
sauf qu'il y av Johnny et là il y a plus
Johnny en fait et malgré tout elles sont
rien à part d'être la fille de Johnny
ALID et je me dis que quand on a 15 ans
et 19 ans s'exprimer comme ça à ce
point-là sur la relation de avec avec
leur papa avec leur maman avec leurs
frères et sœurs et tout ça je trouve que
c'est super violent et j'espère j'espère
que ça va bien se passer pour elle parce
que moi j'ai vachement d'appréhension
quand je vois comment elle se mais ça
fait plus d'un an qu'on demandait
l'interview parce qu'on savait que Jade
aurait avait allait avoir 18 ans euh
donc voilà on on voulait attendre
qu'elle ait 18 ans et ça a pris euh
ouais mais bon ça a pris un an et
demi merci en tout cas merci d'avoir été
avec nous et encore bravo he parce que
ça ça roule bien Ran un dernier mot à
dire oui non enfin moi moi je crois à la
sincérité de de ces deux jeunes filles
lorsqu'elles parlent de leur relation à
leur père je crois je crois vraiment
l'amour qui les unissait euh après elle
donne des explications qui qui sont
terribles quand même encore elle c'est
pour ça que je me dis qu'elles sont
elles sont pas capables de pouvoir
donner ce type d'explication dire bah en
réalité mon frère et et ma grande sœur
agissent comme ça parce qu'ils étaient
jaloux que de l'amour que notre père
nous portait c'est terrible de dire ça
quand même vous voyez c'est ça me ça ça
heur et et et je pense que c'est c'est
quelque chose qui ne peut pas venir
d'elle c'est quelque chose qu' elles
sont beaucoup trop jeunes pour dire ce
genre de choses et et c'est là où je
trouve dommage je trouve que c'est la
limite de de l'exercice de ce qu'elles
ont pu exprimer euh voilà à part cela
évidemment que c'était un très joli coup
de Come et un interview très bien mené
par par Paris Match et et je pense que
voilà elle veut elle veut
aujourd'hui madame ALID veut aujourd'hui
sortir elle veut elle veut elle veut
entrer dans une victimisation pour que
les fans reviennent reviennent en bloc
la
soutenir'exprimera en temps et en heure
au moment de l'exposition merciin merci
Roland merci Benjamin